I'm back, and I just
have to finish up
problem number eighteen.
I just want to make
sure I did this.
10 minus x squared, this will
be x squared minus 20x, plus
100, plus 225.
This is where I always
mess up.
Let's see, what's
325 minus 289?
It's 25 plus 11, so it's 36.
So we're left with 0 is
equal to x squared
minus 20x plus 36.
And now we just have to factor
this right here.
I'll do it up here.
So what two numbers, when you
multiply them, is equal to 36,
and when you add or subtract
them, you get minus 20?
What do you get, let's see.
18 and 2.
18 times 2 is 36.
And if you make them both
negative when they add, they
go to negative 20.
That's x minus 18,
and x minus 2.
I just factored this as x
minus 18 and x minus 2.
And you can review my
presentation on factoring
quadratics if you forgot
how to do this.
But I just said, well
18 times 2 is 36.
And they have to be negative,
because when they add together
you get minus 20.
So x could be equal to 18,
or x could be equal to 2.
And those are the possible
choices.
And that's it.
This was a short video,
just a leftover from
problem number eighteen.
I'll see you in the next